THIS IS SUNDAY MORNING FUTURES.
I’M MARIA BARTIROMO.
LET ME BRING IN FLORIDA GOVERNOR
RON DESANTIS NOW AND GET
REACTION TO WHAT WE HEARD.
GOVERNOR, THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE AND STANDING BY
THROUGHOUT THE LIVE COVERAGE OF
THE G-7 CLOSEOUT MEETING, YOUR
REACTION TO WHAT YOU HEARD FROM
THE PRESIDENT.
GOVERNOR: WELL, MARIA, I THINK
IT’S QUITE A CONTRAST FROM HIS
PREDECESSOR.
I THINK THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
SOMEONE THAT’S MUCH MORE PASSIVE
ON THE WORLD STAGE.
NOT NEARLY AS DYE DONALD TRUMP W
AND I THINK HIS ENERGY LEVEL IS
MUCH LOWER AND SO I THINK THAT’S
JUST SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE ARE
SIZING UP.
I THINK THAT OUR ADVERSARIES ARE
WATCHING THAT.
I DIDN’T HEAR VERY MUCH IN THE
WAY OF HOLDING CHINA ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THEIR ROLE IN COVERING UP
THE ORIGINS OF THE COVID-19
PANDEMIC.
I THINK THAT’S ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL THAT CHINA BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ROLE IN
THAT AS WELL AS ANY BUREAUCRATS
IN THE UNITED STATES WHO MAY
HAVE BEEN COVERING UP.
BUT, YOU KNOW, THEY WERE TALKING
ECONOMICALLY A LOT ABOUT OTHER
COUNTRIES, HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
REDUCING ENERGY PRODUCTION,
WORLDWIDE AND I COULDN’T HELP
BUT THINK, YOU KNOW, HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES, HE’S LEAVING A
LOT OF PEOPLE BEHIND.
LOOK AT ALL THE WORKERS HE LEFT
BEHIND BY CANCELING THE KEYSTONE
XL PIPELINE.
THOSE WERE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF VERY GOOD JOBS AND
ALSO THINK ABOUT FAMILY BUDGETS
WITH THE SHARP INCREASE IN GAS
PRICES AND THEN THE OVERALL
BUTTING INFLATION THAT WE ARE
SEEING THAT’S BEING FUELED BY
BIG-SPENDING POLICIES.
I THINK THAT PERFORMANCE PLAYED
WELL WITH EUROPEAN ELITES.
NOT SURE THAT THERE WAS MUCH IN
IT FOR MIDDLE AMERICA.
MARIA: WE WILL HEAR MORE ABOUT
HIS PLANS FOR TAXES.
HE WANTS TO HAVE A GLOBAL
MINIMUM TAX OF 15%.
IN SOME ECONOMIES THAT WOULD
ACTUALLY BE A TAX INCREASE, IF
YOU LOOK AT A PLACE LIKE
IRELAND.
WE WILL GET MORE ON THAT.
ONE STUDY STRUCK ME BEFORE I WAS
COMING ON THE AIR WITH YOU AND
THIS WAS ABOUT FLORIDA AND IT
SAYS THE AVERAGE TAXPAYER WHO
MOVED TO FLORIDA FROM THE OTHER
49 STATES HAD AN AVERAGE INCOME,
THIS IS AN AVERAGE GROSS INCOME
OF $110,000 WHICH IS ABOUT TWICE
THE AVERAGE HOUSEHOLD INCOME, OF
COURSE, YOU DON’T HAVE INCOME
TAX IN FLORIDA AND IT’S ACTUALLY
HELPED YOUR ECONOMY.
TELL US, ASSESS THE ECONOMY
RIGHT NOW IN FLORIDA AND TELL US
WHAT YOU’VE SEEN OVER THE LAST
YEAR IN TERMS OF AN INCREASE IN
POPULATION.
GOVERNOR: WELL, SURE, MARIA,
BEFORE COVID WE HAD SEEN BY FAR
THE HIGHEST AMOUNT OF WEALTH
MOVE INTO FLORIDA COMPARED TO
ANY OTHER STATE BUT I THINK
THAT’S ACCELERATED SINCE COVID.
I THINK YOU’RE SEEING A LOT OF
PEOPLE MOVE HERE.
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE A VERY
FAVORABLE TAX CLIMATE.
FLORIDA IS THE LOWEST PER CAPITA
TAX BURDEN, INDIVIDUAL TAX
BURDEN IN THE COUNTRY AND WE ARE
PROUD OF THAT.
THAT HAS LED OBVIOUSLY TO MORE
BUSINESSES MOVING HERE.
SO WE’VE GOT A LOT OF GREAT
THINGS ON THE HORIZON BUT IT’S A
LESSON IN HOW YOU DO THIS.
YOU TAX PEOPLE, YOU TAX BUSINESS
AND YOU DO ALL OF THOSE THINGS,
IN A COUNTRY LIKE OURS, IT’S
MOBILE, PEOPLE VOTE WITH THEIR
FEET.
WE HAVE LOW TAXES AND FAVORABLE
ENVIRONMENT AND WE END UPTAKING
MORE REVENUE THAN WE PROBABLY
WOULD IF WE HAD HIGHER TAXES
BECAUSE OF THE UNDERLYING
DYNAMISM OF THE ECONOMY.
MARIA: YEAH, INCREDIBLE.
YOU HAVE BEEN DOING SO MUCH,
GOVERNOR.
I WANT TO GET INTO YOUR MOVES
AND LET ME START WITH THE BILL
THAT YOU JUST SIGNED TO STOP THE
CENSORSHIP OF FLORIDANS.
LAST WEEK ON THE PROGRAM, WE
WENT THROUGH THE FAUCI FACEBOOK
FILES WHERE IT’S CLEAR BASED ON
E-MAILS BETWEEN MARK ZUCKERBERG
AND DR. ANTHONY FAUCI, THEY WERE
COORDINATING IN TERMS OF WHAT
SHOULD BE REPORTED ON FACEBOOK
AND WHAT SHOULDN’T BE.
FACEBOOK TOOK DOWN MANY POSTS
ABOUT THE ORIGIN OF COVID-19
ONLY TO HAVE EGG ON ITS FACE
WHEN THEY HAD TO CHANGE THE
POLICY AGAIN.
DO YOU BELIEVE FAUCI COLLUDED
WITH MARK ZUCKERBERG, DOES THIS
EXPOSE FACEBOOK TO LEGAL ACTION
WHICH IS WHAT SENATOR TED CRUZ
TOLD US LAST WEEK?
>> TOLD US SOMETHING IMPORTANT,
MARIA.
WHAT THEY CENSORED WAS TRUE AND
THEY WERE ALSO CENSORING AROUND
THE SAME TIME LAST YEAR ANY
CRITICISM OF LOCKDOWNS AND WE
KNOW LOCKDOWNS DIDN’T WORK,
STATES LIKE FLORIDA THAT WERE
OPEN WERE BETTER OFF FOR IT AND
SO YOU OFTEN HEAR PEOPLE SAY,
THESE ARE PRIVATE COMPANIES, THE
CAN DO WHAT THEY WANT.
FACEBOOK YOU CAN ARGUE IS
ESSENTIALLY ACTING AS AN ARM OF
THE STATE BECAUSE THEY ARE
SUPPRESSING WHAT THE GOVERNMENT
WANTS SUPPRESSED AND BIG TECH IS
UNLIKE ANYTHING THAT WE HAVE
SEEN.
THEY HAVE MASSIVE AMOUNT OF
POWER, MONOPOLIES STRONGER THAN
THE 20TH CENTURY.
THEY CONTROL HANDFUL OF
COMPANIES.
A HUGE PERCENTAGE OF THE
POLITICAL SPEECH IN THE COUNTRY.
WHEN YOU HAVE SITUATIONS, THEY
ARE NOT JUST CENSORING BASED ON
PARTISANSHIP, WE HAVE SEEN
CONSERVATIVES BEING CENSORED BUT
THE MOST IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT
WE HAVE EVER ADDRESSED, HOW
COVID STARTED, WHETHER LOCKDOWNS
WERE, YOU KNOW THEY ARE DOING
DAMAGE TO SOCIETY.
MARIA: YEAH.
THEY’VE SUDDENLY BELIEVED, COME
TOGETHER THAT THEY ARE THE
ARBITERS OF TRUTH AND MANY OF
THE THINGS THAT THEY ARE
CENSORING ARE, IN FACT, TRUE AS
YOU SAY.
IS FLORIDA CONSIDERING LEGAL
ACTIONS AGAINST FACEBOOK?
GOVERNOR: WELL, I KNOW THAT THE
STATE IS ALREADY INVOLVED IN
MULTI-STATE LITIGATION THAT
PREDATED THOSE REVELATIONS.
I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY I WOULD
SUPPORT ANY WAYS THAT WE CAN
VINDICATE THE RIGHTS OF
INDIVIDUAL FLORIDANS TO BE ABLE
TO CONVERSE ABOUT PUBLIC ISSUES.
NOW OUR BILL IS THE FIRST OF ITS
KIND.
IT REALLY TRACKS WHAT JUSTICE
CLARENCE THOMAS PLAYED OUT IN
ONE OF THE CONCURRENCES A FEW
MONTHS AGO WHERE THESE COMPANIES
REALLY ARE MORE COMMON CARRIERS
AND THEY SHOULD BE TREATED AS
SUCH AND OUR VIEW S YES, YOU CAN
HAVE CERTAIN OBVIOUSLY
GUIDELINES OR HOWEVER YOU DO IT,
BUT YOU HAVE TO APPLY IT EVENLY
AND IF YOU DON’T, YOU ARE
ADVERTISING AS AN OPEN PLATFORM
AND YOU’RE SAYING YOU’RE NOT
PUBLISHERS BUT YOU’RE ACTING AS
PUBLISHERS BY STIFLING SPEECH
THAT YOU DON’T LIKE.
THAT’S A FRAUD ON THE CONSUMER
AND PEOPLE DESERVE TO VINDICATE
RIGHTS IN COURT.
MARIA: I MEAN, THIS CENSORSHIP
FEEL LIKE COMMUNIST CHINA.
YOU TALKED ABOUT BIG TECH AND
RELATIONSHIP TO THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY.
YOU HAVE BEEN RESEARCHING THIS.
YOU SAY THAT THE LOCKDOWN
APPROACH THAT WAS LED BY THE
DEMOCRATS WAS PROMOTED BY THE
CCP.
TELL ME ABOUT THAT.
GOVERNOR: SURE.
BEFORE I DO, JUST POINT OUT,
WHEN WE SIGNED THE BIG-TECH
BILL, I HAD FOLKS WHO HAD FLED
COMMUNIST CUBA SPEAKING ABOUT
HOW IMPORTANT IT WAS.
I HAVE PEOPLE THAT FLED
SOCIALIST VENEZUELA TALKING
ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT IT WAS TO
COMBAT CENSORSHIP BECAUSE THEY
LIVED THROUGH REALLY BAD PERIODS
OF CENSORSHIP.
YOU LOOK AT HOW BIG TECH HAS
HANDLED THE CCP, THEY ARE VERY
DIFFERENTIAL TO THE COMMUNIST
PARTY OF CHINA AND I THINK THAT
CHINA WAS VERY MUCH INVESTED IN
PROMOTING LOCKDOWNS AS WE
STARTED GETTING IN TO 2020,
FEBRUARY, MARCH, OBVIOUSLY
ITALY.
THE ITALY LOCKDOWNS WERE
PATTERNED OFF WHAT WE SAW IN
WUHAN AND FACEBOOK AND SOME OF
THE BIG COMPANIES, THEY WERE
REALLY SERVING TO ELEVATE THE
LOCKDOWN HYSTERIA INTO
ABSOLUTELY SUPPRESSED PEOPLE
THAT WERE RAISES QUESTIONS AND
CONCERNS ABOUT LOCKDOWNS.
AND THE REASON WHY THAT’S SO
GALLING BECAUSE UP UNTIL COVID,
PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE WAS NEVER
IN A PANDEMIC TO JUST LOCK DOWN
INDEFINITELY.
THIS WAS A NEW INVENTION THAT
WAS REALLY FUELED BY THE CHINESE
EXPERIENCE AND SO I THINK THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN BIG TECH
AND THE CCP IS VERY PROBLEMATIC
AND QUITE FRANKLY A LOT OF THESE
BIG CORPORATIONS PARTICULARLY IN
ENTERTAINMENT AND SOME OF THE
OTHER FIELDS OF THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY.
MARIA: AND I WONDER IF IT START
WITH ACADEMIA, GOVERNOR.
YOU KNOW, YOU HEARD PRESIDENT
BIDEN SAY THAT HE WANTS MORE
TRANSPARENCY FROM CHINA, BUT WE
REALLY HAVEN’T SEEN A TOUGH
STANCE IN TERMS OF U.S. POLICY
ON CHINA.
IN FACT, JUST THIS WEEK
PRESIDENT BIDEN REVOKED
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S BAN ON TIKTOK
AND ON WECHAT.
I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE TALKED
ABOUT THE CCP INFILTRATING
FLORIDA UNIVERSITIES, YOU HAVE
CONFUCIUS CENTERS.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT POINT
AND I WANT YOU TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT YOU’RE DOING, THE TWO BILLS
THAT YOU JUST SIGNED IN TERMS OF
STOPPING THE INFLUENCE, FOREIGN
INFLUENCE IN UNIVERSITIES
BECAUSE THE CCP HAS BEEN ABLE TO
GET INSIDE OF IMPORTANT
INSTITUTIONS IN THIS COUNTRY AND
STEAL DATA.
WE KNOW THAT SECRETARY POMPEO
HAS SAID THEY ARE NOW INSIDE THE
GATES.
THERE WAS A STRING OF
INDICTMENTS IN 2020 BY THE
POMPEO STATE DEPARTMENT.
EVERYONE FROM A -- THE HEAD OF
THE BIOLOGY DEPARTMENT AT
HARVARD TO AN NYPD OFFICER TO
SHUTTING DOWN THE EMBASSY IN
HOUSTON.
THEY DO GET INSIDE OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS, WHAT CAN YOU DO TO
STOP IT AND TELL ME ABOUT THOSE
CONFUCIUS CENTERS IN FLORIDA?
GOVERNOR: SO WE DID TWO BILLS,
ONE TO COMBAT FOREIGN INFLUENCE
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED AT THE CPP
AND CORPORATE ESPIONAGE WHICH IS
GENERALLY TARGETED AT THE CCP
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE WORST
OFFENDERS.
SO WE ACTUALLY HAD A CONFUCIUS
INSTITUTE THAT WAS DONE AT
MIAMI-DADE COLLEGE.
FORTUNATELY WHEN I BECAME
GOVERNOR WE LOOKED AT AND WE HAD
COLLEGE GET RID OF IT, HOWEVER,
THIS IS A CONTINUED CONCERN.
OUR BILL WE SIGNED BASICALLY
BANS THINGS LIKE CONFUCIUS
INSTITUTES FROM GETTING A
FOOTHOLD ON FLORIDA UNIVERSITIES
AND I THINK THAT’S REALLY
IMPORTANT BUT AS YOU DOCUMENT,
IT SEEMS LIKE EVERY OTHER WEEK
THEY’LL BE ACADEMIC RESEARCHER
WHO IS IDENTIFIED AS HAVING TIES
WITH THE CCP.
PEOPLE GET INDICTED, PEOPLE FLEE
AMERICA ONCE THEY ARE FOUND OUT
ABOUT THIS AND SO WE ARE REALLY
TRYING TO SCRUTINIZE WHAT’S
GOING ON IN THESE UNIVERSITIES
INSIDE FLORIDA.
WE ALSO WANT TO PROTECT TRADE
SECRETS FROM OUR BUSINESSES AND
ALL THAT BECAUSE CCP
INFILTRATION HAS BEEN VERY
PROMINENT THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
BUT, MA’AM, THE ACADEMIA,
THERE’S DEEP TIES IN MANY
SEGMENTS OF ACADEMIA WITH THE
COMMUNIST PARTY OF CHINA.
MARIA: I WANT YOU TO HEAR
PRESIDENT BIDEN TALK ABOUT XI
JINPING RECENTLY.
I WAS ASTOUNDED AT THE COMMENTS
AND, AGAIN, WE STILL DO NOT HAVE
A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
BIDEN’S POLICY IS ON CHINA.
HERE HE IS JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO.
WATCH THIS, GOVERNOR.
>> I’VE SPENT MORE TIME WITH
PRESIDENT XI OF CHINA THAN ANY
WORLD LEADER HAS, 24 HOURS OF
PRIVATE MEETINGS WITH HIM, JUST
AN INTERPRETER.
17,000 MILES TRAVELING CHINA AND
HERE.
HE FIRMLY BELIEVES THAT CHINA
BEFORE THE YEAR 2035 IS GOING TO
OWN AMERICA BECAUSE OF AUTACRACI
WE ARE THE ONLY NATION ORGANIZED
ON AN IDEA.
MARIA: THAT’S IT, GOVERNOR.
XI JINPING, THE PRESIDENT OF
CHINA THINKS HE WILL OWN AMERICA
WITHIN 15 YEARS.
THAT’S WHAT YOU HEARD FROM
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
GOVERNOR: IT’S REALLY
ASTOUNDING.
THE ORIGINS OF COVID, ONE OF THE
BIGGEST COVER-UPS IN THE HISTORY
OF THE COUNTRY IN TERMS OF WHAT
THEY DID WITH THE GAIN OF
FUNCTION RESEARCH, UNDERSTANDING
THAT THESE RESEARCHERS HAD BEEN
INFECTED IN THE FALL OF 2019 AND
THEN TO COVER IT UP FOR MONTHS
AND THEN TO NOT BE VIEWED AT IS
SOMETHING OF UPMOST IMPORTANCE
TO BE ABLE TO, ONE, GET THE
TRUTH, BUT TO HOLD CHINA
ACCOUNTABLE.
THEY CAUSED IMMENSE DAMAGE
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD BY ALLOWING
THIS -- THIS VIRUS TO BE
UNLEARNED ON THE REST OF THE
WORLD AND SO TO BE THAT
DIFFERENTIAL TO CHINA, I DON’T
THINK THAT’S WHAT THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC IS LOOKING FOR.
I THINK THAT THEY WANT TO SEE A
POLICY FROM THE UNITED STATES
THAT’S MORE ASSERTIVE AGAINST
CHINA AND UNDERSTANDS CHINA IS A
THREAT.
THEY’RE AN ECONOMIC COMPETITOR
BUT ALSO A THREAT IN TERMS OF
WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO ACHIEVE
MILITARILY.
MARIA: GOVERNOR, REAL QUICK
BEFORE WE GO.
SET THE RECORD STRAIGHT ON THE
CRUISE INDUSTRY.
I KNOW THERE’S A NARRATIVE BEING
PUSHED BY THE MEDIA THAT YOU’RE
IN A WAR IN THE CRUISE INDUSTRY
WHETHER OR NOT TO REQUIRE
VACCINE PASSPORTS.
WHERE ARE YOU WITH THE CRUISE
INDUSTRY AND WHAT SHOULD
AMERICANS EXPECT?
GOVERNOR: WELL, WE ARE IN THE
FIGHT WITH THE CDC.
WE DON’T BELIEVE THEY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DO THAT.
WE ARE SUING THEM IN FEDERAL
COURT.
WE HAD A HEARING LAST WEEK, VERY
POSITIVE RESPONSE FROM THE
COURT.
WE THINK WE WILL GET A FAVORABLE
RULING THERE AND WE DEFINITELY
THINK WE WILL WIN ON APPEAL AS
WELL.
ONCE WE ARE PASSED THE CDC, THEY
ARE FREE TO SAIL IN FLORIDA.
OF COURSE, THEY WILL HAVE TO
FOLLOW FLORIDA LAW BUT THEY WILL
BE ABLE TO DO IT WITHOUT
REQUIRING VACCINE PASSPORTS.
YOU KNOW, THE CDC, MARIA, THEY
DON’T RECOGNIZE IMMUNITY
CONFERRED THROUGH INFECTION AND
WE KNOW THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
TENS OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE IMMUNITY THROUGH THAT WAY.
WHY WOULD YOU SAY THEY CAN’T
PARTICIPATE IN SOCIETY, WHY DO
WE WANT PEOPLE TO BE DIVULGING
ALL OF THE HEALTH INFORMATION
AND WE HAVE A BLANKET BAN ON
THAT ACROSS THE STATE OF FLORIDA
BUT WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT ONCE
CDC GETS OUT OF THE WAY THAT YOU
WILL SEE CRUISES RESUME IN
FLORIDA VERY SOON.
MARIA: GOVERNOR, REALLY QUICK
BEFORE YOU GO.
YOU HAVE BEEN SHOWING REAL
LEADERSHIP IN A VERY DIFFICULT
TIME.
HAVE YOU HAD SERIOUS DISCUSSIONS
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP ABOUT
PARTNERING WITH HIM IN 2024 AND
A RUN?
GOVERNOR: NO.
AND I HAVEN’T HAD ANY
DISCUSSIONS WITH ANYBODY ABOUT
ANYTHING BEYOND WHAT WE ARE
DOING NOW BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, WE
ARE PUTTING A LOT OF POINTS ON
THE BOARD AND WE ARE REALLY
GOING ON OFFENSE, MOVING THE
BALL FORWARD.
I HAVE A GREAT STATE, A BIG
STATE.
WE’VE GOT A LOT ON OUR PLATE
HERE.
WE TAKE IT ONE DAY AT A TIME AND
TRY TO ACHIEVE THINGS FOR THE
PEOPLE OF THE FLORIDA.
MARIA: GOVERNOR, YOU’RE DOING A
GREAT JOB, WE APPRECIATE YOUR